This is the brief on patriotism
and the default Republic.
So America's heading towards its
250th birthday in 2026, right?
The semi quicentennial.
And our source material points
out something kind of wild.
The progressive establishment
tried this strategic move,
faking patriotism, but it's
actually turning them into real
believers.
Like genuinely, how is that even
happening?
OK, let's break down the three
key things going on here.
First, there's a strategy called
the Great Patriotic Heist.
Basically, the left, panicked,
decided to act all patriotic,
wrap their ideas in the flag,
you know, to stop patriotism
from being just a right wing
thing.
But, and this is the kicker, the
performance is backfiring.
The source says the self becomes
what it pretends to be.
So the acting, it's becoming
real.
Second, what's really driving
this change?
It's something called the
default Republic.
Think of it as the the quiet
majority, maybe the 80%, the
folks who keep the country going
just by habit, not hardcore
ideology and their power move.
It's like cultural judo.
They don't argue or fight back,
they just kind of absorb the
opposition with patience and
friendliness.
Finally, there's this cool
metaphor, Rumspringa.
The idea is the left is on this
sort of required field trip,
right going to flag waving
events, experiencing regular
America.
And it turns out just being
around that simple belonging,
that basic niceness, it's way
more powerful than all the
academic critiques.
It's leading to this accidental
conversion.
So the big picture, the Republic
basically just outlast its
critics, absorbs them through
contact, waits for them to get
tired of fighting today.
We're digging into patriotism
and the default Republic between
the heist and the conversion.
Right.
So the piece looks at the left
using patriotic themes for the
250th, and how that might
accidentally trigger a real
shift back towards sincerity via
the default Republic.
It's a fascinating idea, great
premise.
Definitely.
And we've got three main
thoughts on how to make that
core argument even stronger.
Really.
Land it.
OK.
So First off, the concept of the
default Republic, that sort of
quiet, non ideological 80%
having this power to just absorb
opposition, that's the core
strength here.
Absolutely.
It's potent.
But the critique is that it's
power could be shown more
clearly if we detailed the
mechanism of its cultural judo.
Right now we mostly just see the
result.
Yeah, I agree with that.
The weakness, I think, is that
it says the Republic absorbs,
metabolizes all that, which is
compelling.
But the focus tends to be on the
psychology of the people being
converted.
You know, the elites doing their
room springa or the whole Sartre
acting becomes believing thing.
Right, so the attention is on
the person changing.
Exactly.
And that leaves the Republic
itself, the thing doing, the
absorbing it feeling a little,
well, passive, almost like
scenery, even though we're told
it's the main force.
We know it wins, but we don't
quite see how it applies the
pressure day-to-day.
OK, yeah, we get that it's the
ballast, the immune system.
The author calls it the majority
just sustaining things through
habit.
But what is that immune system
actually do?
How does it actively push back
against the the cynicism from
the Monastery of Critique?
Well, the suggestion is maybe
shift the lens just a bit.
You know, focus on those
specific very normal, non
ideological civic spaces or the
cultural rituals, the places
where the default Republic
basically demands sincerity.
OK, That's how you show the
conversion being forced.
You illustrate how those
systems, those everyday things
are the immune system in action.
You show the pressure.
That's definitely actionable,
but I wonder, are we risking
focusing too much on like the
physical spaces and maybe losing
sight of the political
calculation behind the heist
itself?
That ironic distance is kind of
needed for the elites to even
try it, right?
Oh, for sure.
The political motive is the
spark, the catalyst.
But these civic spaces, they're
the lab.
That's where the experiment
actually happens, where the
conversion gets real.
OK.
So for a concrete example, don't
just state that the Republic
endures.
Show us.
Show us the institutions that
make irony collapse.
Think about things that require
participation, things run by the
default Republic that value
choreography and
unselfconsciousness, as the
author puts it.
Give me an example.
Where does irony just fail?
Well, think about something
really basic, like the local
Scout troop organizing the
Memorial Day parade, or having
to show up for high school
sports night.
Or even, and this might sound
odd, the simple ritual of Tax
Day.
Tax Day.
That's interesting.
Why Tax Day?
Is it just the sheer
bureaucratic weight of being a
citizen?
Like you can't posture your way
through a 1040.
Pretty much these things force
sincerity, or at least the
performance of it so
consistently it becomes real.
You can't fill out tax forms
ironically.
You can't really stand there,
ironically, watching the parade
without just failing, socially
failing.
Right, you stick out, but not in
the cool detached way.
Exactly.
It forces the elite, the ones
used to that intellectual
distance, to drop the shield
just to get through it.
It uses their own attempt at
joining in against them.
I see so use that rowers in the
galley analogy the author has
show them applying the pressure,
the sheer force of required
community stuff making it tough
for the coxswain shouting
slogans, the elite to just keep
performing cynicism.
Show the boring stuff winning.
Precisely show the default
Republic not as some abstract
idea, but as this kind of
mandatory social gravity.
It demands submission
eventually.
That really hammers home the
point that sincerity isn't
naive, it's actually power.
OK, that's strong.
Let's move to the second big
opportunity.
This one's about the language,
which is fantastic.
All these analogies, heist
conversion, Rumspringa, cultural
judo, BBQ versus bonfire.
I mean, the inventiveness here
is really something.
Oh, absolutely.
It's incredibly rich.
But, and this is the flip side,
the sheer density of these
powerful metaphors, these high
concept labels, sometimes they
almost compete for attention.
You know it can slightly dilute
the main thrust.
Right.
The weakness is that each one is
brilliant on its own.
Like that line about the
fireworks show needing a moral
disclaimer.
Fantastic.
But put them all together and
it's almost like a metaphorical
traffic jam.
Yeah, a reader might kind of
struggle to figure out which one
carries the core thesis.
Is it the psychology, the
rumpspringer, or the big
structure?
The default Republic or the
political act?
The heist?
Which one is driving?
So the suggestion here is maybe
consolidate that framework a
bit, pick the one or two
absolutely crucial metaphors
that really hold that central
tension.
Which ones would you pick?
I'd argue for Rumspringa that
captures the personal
psychological journey and then
default Republic for the
underlying structural reality.
Those feel like the core poles.
OK.
Then you could recast the other
really strong analogies as like
functions or phases within that
main structure.
Give them jobs to do for the
main metaphors.
Ah, establish A hierarchy so the
essay structure mirrors the
thesis instead of having all
these concepts running in
parallel.
Exactly.
Take the great patriotic Heist.
Super sticky phrase.
Very memorable, but maybe
reframe it.
Don't present it as a totally
separate thing, but explicitly
call it the trigger, the
initiating phase, the thing that
kicks off the rumspring up.
Right connects the political
strategy directly to the
psychological result.
Makes the flow much cleaner.
Gives it narrative drive.
Yeah, and what about the coda,
the bonfire and the BBQ?
That's powerful, too.
Super powerful, so they're just
make the take away crystal
clear.
Use the BBQ explicitly to
represent the default republic's
method, that communion based on,
you know, shared appetite,
simple belonging, and then state
directly that this method, this
quiet absorption, is ultimately
stronger, more lasting than the
elites method of intellectual
control, The bonfire.
Make sure that final image
clearly says which form of
community wins out.
So basically use concepts like
cultural judo more as the how.
It's the description of the
default Republic's patient
method, not another competing
idea alongside Rumspringa and
Heist.
Perfect.
The default Republic uses
cultural judo to manage the
elites from Springa, which was
started by the heist.
Something like that.
Exactly like that.
Let the metaphors serve the main
point, not fight over becoming
the main point themselves.
OK, clear.
Our final area then #3 is about
backing this up with history,
structural evidence.
Let's look at Section 2,
Patriotism's menu reboots.
Very smart section necessary,
but it feels a bit separate
right now.
I agree that historical context
is really sophisticated, but
it's kind of siloed off.
It needs to be woven directly
into the main argument.
Use it as the evidence for how
this absorption thing works.
Yeah, The weakness is that the
main story focuses so much on
right now, the 2024 to 2026 push
for inclusive patriotism.
And while the idea of absorption
is historical, the essay notes,
you know, Puritans became
merchants, etcetera.
The actual section detailing
those historical reboots like
17761865 or 18901945, it sits
apart from the core analysis of
how the conversion happens now.
And that makes the current semi
quincentennial thing feel maybe
like a one off, a new political
trick, instead of seeing it as
just the latest round in a
historical pattern that, as the
essay argues, always plays out
the same way.
OK, the piece argues, the
Republic is durable, but the
history needs to be right there
proving that durability right
when the mechanism itself is
being explained.
So the suggestion is
straightforward.
Use those historical cycles as
direct named proof points for
the core mechanisms.
Really strengthen the claim that
this default republics
temperament, this absorption, it
always wins in the end.
Absolutely.
For example, when you introduce
that idea.
Sincerity isn't naivete, it's
power right there.
Bring in a historical example.
Show the template for the
current heist.
Like what?
Like.
Maybe reference the Civic Gospel
era, say 1890 to 1945.
That's when the progressive
movement successfully folded its
reform ideas.
Creating national parks, pushing
public education, folded them
into patriotic duty.
Ah.
So it shows the system's knack
for taking potentially
disruptive ideas and making them
part of the establishment.
Rebellion becomes
administration.
Exactly.
And that idea you mentioned,
conflict, getting metabolized
into unfinished work, that
metabolic forgiveness that's
profoundly historical.
It almost feels like the system
forgets its own hypocrisies
quickly through this process.
Yeah, it.
Absorbs the critique and just
moves on incorporating it.
So use.
History to show that process
when you bring up Hegel thesis
antithesis synthesis maybe
explicitly link the chaotic
Republic of rebellion 1776 to
1865 to how Lincoln then
redefined patriotism as this
kind of moral labor OK it shows
how massive national conflict
gets turned into ongoing non
cynical civic work it proves the
process has deep roots that.
Definitely elevates it.
It makes the argument feel less
like just a clever take on
current events and more like
uncovering A fundamental law of
how America works.
Shows the inevitability, right?
Longevity and inevitability, OK.
This has been really good.
So to recap the main
opportunities we see first
really detail the active
mechanism of the default
Republic show.
Don't just tell using those
specific civic spaces where
sincerity is basically
mandatory.
Uh huh.
Make that cultural judo visible.
Second, tighten U that brilliant
metahorical structure.
Consolidate around the core ones
like Rumsringa and default
Republic.
Maybe make the others serve
those key concets in a clear
hierarchy, right?
Like heist leading to Rumsringa.
And finally weave those
historical cycles directly into
the main argument.
Use them as the primary proof
that this absorption mechanism
isn't new, it's the pattern show
the current heist is just the
latest reboot.
Exactly.
So the core actionable thing is
use the fantastic analysis
already there to show the
absorption happening, focus on
those unavoidable points of
civic contact, and back it up
with the history.
That will really solidify the
argument that America's genius
isn't really persuasion.
It's this quiet, relentless
hospitality and absorption.
Excellent.
Points really looking forward to
seeing the next version of this
please do submit it back to us
when you're ready the debate we.
Love to take another look.
Our focus today is a major
cultural phenomenon the the
highly visible and often, let's
say, paradoxical embrace of
traditional American patriotism
by elements of the managerial
and cultural elite, especially
as we move toward the nation's
semi quincentennial, the 250th
anniversary of its founding.
And we're observing really a
dramatic shift where
institutions and and individuals
that, you know, historically
treated national symbols with
profound skepticism are now
actively championing their
reclamation and, and
redefinition.
Exactly.
So the central question
animating this moment is whether
this sudden pivot this this
adoption of red, white and blue
imagery, is it calculated,
cynical strategic maneuver aimed
at neutralizing political
opposition?
Or is it perhaps a necessary and
genuine act of moral repair and
civic healing for the nation?
Now, I tend to hold that this
conversion of critics is
structurally inevitable, driven
by the sheer overwhelming and
frankly patient power of what we
might call the default Republic
to absorb and domesticate its
opposition.
The system, I think, is designed
to win.
That's a.
Powerful claim about
inevitability, but I I come at
it from a different perspective
regarding agency.
I believe this phenomenon, while
yes, undeniably timed for
strategic advantage, what some
might label the Great Patriotic
Heist is better understood as a
long delayed reconciliation.
It's a genuine and vital civic
rehearsal necessary to align our
national symbols with modern
conscience, serving, I'd argue,
as therapy rather than theft.
Well, I.
Maintain that this shift is
driven by deep strategic panic.
The progressive establishment
realized, I think, that they
couldn't afford to simply, you
know, sneer at the flag and the
founders while others
exclusively claimed the
narrative of the 250th
anniversary.
So their calculation the heist
is simple.
Neutralize patriotism as a right
wing brand by performing love of
country.
This involves A wrapping
progressive moral aims in
traditional symbolism.
But this performance, and this
is key, is highly risky because
it practically guarantees
genuine conversion.
As as thinkers like Sartre
observed regarding bad faith,
the self inevitably becomes what
it pretends to be.
Even if the pretense was
initially purely instrumental,
the ritual of patriotic
belonging eventually settles
into sincere belief and.
When you speak of the default
Republic, just for clarity, you
mean the the enduring sort of
unselfconscious mainstream of
American life, The 80% maybe who
pay taxes, coach Little League,
and and don't require an
ideology to justify their
belonging.
Is that fair?
Precisely.
Yes.
It is the patient enduring
center.
And this center doesn't resist
the performers, it welcomes
them.
The default Republic acts as a
cultural mechanism, employing
what I called cultural judo.
It absorbs opposition not
through argument or repression,
but well through hospitality.
It exposes the intellectual
critics to the simple,
unselfconscious belonging found
in everyday American life.
The backyard BBQ, The small town
parade.
The system initiates a kind of
national rum sringer, you could
say.
A temporary license to reject,
knowing that the freedom and
simplicity of the community will
ultimately call the Exiles home.
Patriotism here is choreography.
It's instinct.
It's repetition.
And repetition, as we know, is
the engine of belief I.
Agree that repetition is
powerful, but I I strongly
disagree that this process is
purely A structural
inevitability or just cultural
judo.
What you label the Heist is, I
think, better understood as a
generational correction and
overdue a recognition that
loyalty to the national project
and a vigorous critique of its
current reality are not mutually
exclusive.
This act of wrapping modern
ideals such as, say, inclusive
patriotism or a moral reckoning
with history is not theft, It is
therapy.
It's the historical method of
renewal America has always used.
Think of the pattern.
Every moral renewal starts as a
necessary appropriation and ends
as a new Canon.
The abolitionist stole the
founders language of liberty and
equality to undermine slavery.
Martin Luther King Junior?
Well, he borrowed Jefferson's
soaring cadence and the
framework work of the
Declaration to call in the
nation's moral debt.
This isn't passive absorption.
This is active moral labor.
That historical.
Parallel is compelling, I grant
you.
However, if the intent is purely
instrumental, you know, to
control the political narrative,
then the moral labor is well,
it's secondary to the strategy,
isn't it?
But intent?
Matters less, perhaps, than the
function it serves for the
broader society.
If the new patriotism feels
scripted, maybe that's because
sincerity, after decades of
cultural war, has to be
relearned publicly.
Through repetition, a society
that stops pretending to believe
in itself eventually stops
existing, whether that's through
cynicism or factionalism.
This repetition, even if
initially coerced by strategy,
is a vital civic rehearsal
necessary to suspend the
democracy against corrosive
disillusionment.
The appropriation is the
antidote to the cynicism.
OK, but.
I believe the mechanism of the
default Republic is
fundamentally stronger than the
managerial classes intention.
Let's focus on the motive for a
second.
I'd argue the impetus for this
heist is rooted in a kind of
sublimated envy.
The elites, the credentialed
class, perhaps the envy.
Those who belong without needing
permission, without a footnote,
without a degree validating
their existence.
They desire the simple, unearned
belonging of the mainstream,
Their attempt at control.
The heist will fail because the
default Republic doesn't need to
argue with them.
It wins by forgiveness, not by
victory.
The Republic simply indoors and
hosts the party, waiting for the
zealots, regardless of their
political alignment, to exhaust
their fury and, well, tire
themselves out.
You're presenting.
The default Republic is this
sort of philosophical, almost
Hegelian force, a relentless
self correcting Organism, and
the managerial class is acting
purely from what?
Psychological pathology?
But historical context shows
that profound reboots of
patriotism are rarely initiated
by passive cultural osmosis
alone.
They are frequently and
necessarily initiated by intense
moral labor and critique from
the outside.
The very act of redefining the
flags meaning saying it stands
for something new, something
more inclusive, is essential for
a Republic that survived a civil
war, world wars and the civil
rights movement.
The temple of this shift may
indeed seem cynical.
Yes, time perfectly for the
250th, but the goal is
fundamentally a moral 1 to align
the national myth with
contemporary conscience.
This mirrors the Progressive
Era, which actively married
patriotism to reform concepts
like public health initiatives,
settlement houses, mandatory
public education.
These were cast as patriotic
duties requiring conscious
political and moral steering.
Not just passive absorption, but
moral.
Steering requires an audience
that's, well, listening, and the
genius of the cultural judo I
described is that it absorbs the
reformer without necessarily
adopting the entirety of the
reformist doctrine.
The managerial class is
attempting to hijack a symbol of
belonging.
The Republic simply opens its
arms and takes them in.
When you embrace the symbols,
you expose yourself to the
temperament that created them, a
temperament that, I'd argue
values cohesion, often over
complexity.
I.
Disagree.
I think the flag survives
because it contains the
complexity.
It's not an end state.
The moral energy unleashed by
the heist, as you call it, is
actually a positive force.
It means the people leading the
cultural conversation have
decided that rather than burning
the system down, they must
occupy its symbols to redirect
it.
That effort, that moral
wrestling, is precisely what
prevents the default Republic
from becoming near inertia or
simple empty nostalgia.
But that.
Complexity is exactly what the
patriotism of the default
Republic tends to reject, or at
least sideline.
Patriotism, at its baseline, is
fundamentally about
unselfconsciousness.
It's built by osmosis, by
reciting the pledge in school,
attending the local fair,
watching fireworks, not by
reading policy papers or
engaging in constitutional
arguments.
It is the permission to love
something vast and imperfect
without requiring A footnote
detailing all its flaws.
The freedom implied by the
rumspring of metaphor is key
here.
The freedom from constant
resentment and the need to
critique every single
interaction, well, that tastes
better than any policy proposal.
The radical hospitality of the
system means it doesn't punish
hypocrisy or initial
insincerity.
You merely have to show up, and
the act of showing up is the
conversion mechanism.
That's a.
Compelling argument for the
cultural power of, let's say,
ease.
But have you considered the
possibility that patriotism must
be moral labor?
That it's a constant commitment
that requires the rewriting and
reaffirmation of national
purpose?
The goal of this heist is
healing isn't simple, unexamined
belonging, but rather a profound
responsibility for the future.
This contrasts sharply, I think,
with a conservative emphasis
that sometimes leans towards
mere gratitude for the past.
The country desperately needs
this public conscious effort to
create the conditions for
belief.
We must actively inject modern
conscience into the symbols,
otherwise those symbols atrophy.
You mentioned the insight that a
society that stops pretending to
believe in itself eventually
stops existing.
Well, that means we must
actively choose the scripted
belief over the dangers of
cynicism and apathy.
I remain suspicious of the need
for the script.
The scripted nature implies an
elite managing the emotions of
the masses.
If this is a necessary process
of moral labor, why does it
require this highly
choreographed, seemingly top
down strategy of appropriation?
If the belief were truly
organic, wouldn't the symbols
naturally shift over time?
The fact that this feels
engineered suggests, to me at
least, that the managerial class
is prioritizing political
utility over genuine civic
renewal.
They want the power of the
symbol without the
unselfconscious, sometimes messy
reality of the people who
already hold it dear.
Perhaps it?
Feels engineered because the
symbols have been monopolized,
or at least heavily contested
for decades, and the civic
language required to discuss
loyalty, dissent, and pride
constructively has been, well,
broken.
We are, in a sense, relearning
the language publicly.
This isn't cynical manipulation,
necessarily.
It could be seen as social
engineering required to repair a
fractured national narrative.
If we wait for perfect organic
sincerity, we might wait
forever.
The perceived moral necessity
dictates the tempo of the
political action.
Here we might.
Summarize our disagreement using
that central metaphor from the
source material.
The default Republic is the BBQ,
messy, smoky, uncurated, where
people share plates, argue about
sports, and achieve a simple
communion built on proximity and
shared experience.
The heist, in contrast, was the
bonfire of protest, the effort
to burn down and rebuild the
myth from scratch.
The Republic, I argue, always
wins because it rewards
appetite, the simple desire for
food and community, not
doctrine.
The semi quincentennial will
succeed in uniting people not
through sophisticated
ideological agreement, but
through simple exhaustion and
proximity.
People will simply tire of
hating each other.
Look for a place to sit down
and, you know, wander over to
where the food is regardless of
who's flipping the burgers while
the.
Appeal of the BBQ that simple,
messy communion is undeniable.
I argue that the appropriation
of the symbols, the heist is
critical precisely because it
forces the synthesis.
The fire of protest and critique
is essential for refining the
national spirit.
The flag only survives because
it belongs to whoever keeps
arguing under it, forcing that
Hegelian dialectic forward, if
you will.
The managerial class is bringing
the fire to the BBQ, forcing a
mixing of ideals that is messy,
yes, but necessary.
Look at recent social movements
like the No Kings movement,
which utilized patriotic
pageantry in 1776 themes to
frame contemporary political
dissent.
This proves, I think, that
descent must operate within the
national framework.
It's a necessary re channeling
of critical energy that actively
repairs the civic fabric.
Without the intense heat of that
moral fire, the BBQ risks
becoming just empty sentimental
nostalgia that serves no real
forward purpose but the.
Default Republic's genius is
that it diffuses that heat.
It doesn't extinguish the fire,
it merely uses the warmth,
perhaps to cook the food.
The act of using the symbols
dilutes the radicalism, and the
symbol itself ultimately
domesticates the user.
The managerial class believes
they are using the Default
Republic.
I suspect that Default Republic
is simply waiting for them to
accept its terms.
Conclusion.
So in the end, regardless of the
elite strategy, they're
calculated heist.
I believe the underlying
temperament of the Default
Republic will win out.
It is patient, it's erratically
forgiving, and it's focused on
endurance, ensuring that this
maneuver is domesticated into a
sincere conversion.
The performance will and time
become belief, and the critics
who arrived late and perhaps
reluctantly, will be welcomed
home, handed a plate, and
invited to stay.
That unconditional welcome, that
willingness to absorb all past
critique into the ongoing
national narrative, will succeed
where ideology often fails.
And I.
Conclude that the shift we are
witnessing is a reflection of
historical inevitability in a
different sense, the sheer
necessity of generational
renewal.
Every generation must redefine
loyalty and patriotism to
survive its own challenges.
The generation of 1776 defined
patriotism as treason against
the Crown.
The generation of 1945 perhaps
defined it as conformity and
sacrifice.
Our generation seems to be
defining it through lenses of
trauma, accountability and
complexity.
The current movement is a vital,
even if sometimes awkward, step
to ensure the survival of the
Republic by making its symbols
large enough and flexible enough
to hold modern conscience and
our complex, often contradictory
history.
The material certainly presents
2 strong, credible ways to view
this moment as a masterful
underlying cultural system
absorbing its opposition,
proving that maybe America's
genius lies in its hospitality
and patient endurance, or as an.
Active, conscious and necessary
moral process essential for
democracy survival.
Proving that the flag remains
the ultimate open mic, so to
speak, for whoever chooses to
argue under it, the Semi
Quincentennial will undoubtedly
be the Crucible that we're the
place you.
Come to get complex cultural
stuff broken down, synthesized,
and hopefully made clear.
That's the.
Goal.
And today we've got a really
fascinating one.
It's all about American
identity, patriotism and, well,
a kind of strategic rebranding
effort.
Yeah.
And it centers around something
big coming up America's 250th
birthday, which, by the way, has
an official name.
That's quite something.
Oh, you mean the?
Semi quincentennial, that's the.
One the semi quincentennial it
just rolls off the tongue,
doesn't it not?
Exactly.
It's kind of awkward,
bureaucratic even, right?
And.
The sources we looked at really
pick up on that, that
awkwardness, that sort of
managerial feel of the word
itself.
It perfectly signals the whole
approach being taken to this
huge national moment.
It does.
Feel less like a spontaneous
celebration and more like a
carefully planned corporate
event.
Or maybe it required seminar.
Exactly.
And that feeling points directly
to the well, the central paradox
we're diving into today.
It's just this really.
Sharp U-turn we've seen in the
cultural landscape, yeah.
I mean, think back just a few
years for certain segments of
the, let's call it the elite or
managerial class, the flag
patriotism, these are often seen
as problematic, right?
Definitely.
Criticized, analyzed, often
linked to things like empire or,
you know, moral failings.
There was a lot of critique and
now?
Suddenly the message from those
same corners is very different.
It's basically everyone, get on
board, participate, go buy a
flag.
It's quite the.
Shift the The high priests of
irony, as one source put it, are
now kind of leading this
mandatory pilgrimage towards
sincerity, which.
Feels inherently awkward,
probably for everyone involved,
especially those being asked to
make that pivot so quickly.
And the source.
Material is pretty clear.
This isn't some sudden organic
wave of newfound belief.
This feels calculated,
strategic.
Yes.
Strategic and driven, frankly by
political necessity more than
anything else.
OK, so that's.
Our mission for this deep dive,
we need to unpack this whole
dynamic, and the sources give us
a really useful three-part
framework, right we've got.
The heist, it's the top down
attempt to grab and manage the
narrative then.
There's the pretending, the
whole psychological piece about
what happens when you perform
belief even if you don't
initially feel it, and.
Finally, the default Republic.
This sort of quiet, maybe
underestimated, absorbing force
that the sources argue will
ultimately shape how 2026
actually plays out sounds like
a.
Plan.
Let's start with Part 1, The
heist, or as the sources call
it, the Great Patriotic Heist.
OK.
So the definition here is pretty
specific.
It's described as the
progressive establishments
strategic very top down attempt
to basically stage manage
patriots stage.
Manage it without actually, you
know, believing in it
beforehand.
Exactly.
Without that genuine
pre-existing internal belief,
it's framed as a purely pre
emptive move, a narrative strike
almost designed to.
Do what?
What was the goal to?
Neutralize a political advantage
someone else had and the core.
Driver behind this It wasn't
some grand vision for Unity.
Not according.
To the sources, the primary
motivation described is that,
well, panic, strategic panic,
panic.
Like realizing you've let the
other side completely own a
powerful set of symbols.
Precisely.
That it was reactive, the
analysis suggests that elites
looked across the political
landscape, saw the populist
movement particularly.
Trump and his supporters, right
And they?
Saw them getting ready to
basically monopolize the entire
run up to the 200 and fiftieths.
We're talking three years
turning it.
Into one long campaign rally.
Essentially, that's how it was.
Perceived, yeah, a massive
continuous rally and that felt
like a direct threat to the
establishments ability to
control the story, the narrative
authority it makes.
Sense If you spend years
defining the flag and patriotism
as inherently problematic, you
can't really be shocked when
someone else picks them up and
claims them as their brand.
That sort of intellectual
stance, that ambivalence,
suddenly became a huge strategic
problem, a liability.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So the thinking shifted.
A new script was needed fast the
if.
You can't beat them.
Steal their symbols approach.
Kind of.
Steal the symbols and rebrand
them.
And this heist, as it's called,
had some very specific goals.
OK, what were?
They objective.
Number one, perform love of
country, do it loudly, do it
visibly and do it long enough to
basically.
Dilute the brand to stop the
flag being seen as exclusively a
right wing symbol.
Exactly.
Neutralize it.
It was described as a massive
nationwide de weaponization
campaign for the symbols
themselves and this.
Leads to what the sources call
synthetic patriotism.
That's the.
Term used yes, synthetic
patriotism.
It's not about, you know,
organically embracing existing
traditions or feelings.
It's more like.
Taking progressive ideas, modern
olicy goals, things like that
right and.
Wrapping them U in red, white
and blue bunting.
Using the aesthetic of
patriotism to promote a
different agenda.
It's calculated branding,
replacing organic tradition.
Can you give?
An example of what that looks
like in practice?
Sure.
Think about, say, a big
corporate statement that comes
out on the 4th of July, OK, and
maybe it mentions the flag,
mentions America, but then it
spends most of its time talking
about the company's commitment
to, I don't know, climate goals
or DEI metrics.
Right.
So it uses the patriotic
occasion, but.
Immediately pivots the meaning
towards very current, very
specific political or social
objectives.
The patriotism is almost a
veneer, a way to deliver a
different message.
Got it.
OK, so neutralize the flag was
objective one.
What was next on the heist
script objective?
2 was a crucial rhetorical
shift, replacing the historical
anchor of 1776.
Replacing it.
With what?
With this.
Constant emphasis on unfinished
work.
OK, that's clever.
Tell me more about why that
shift is significant.
Well, think.
About it.
Focusing on 1776 tends to evoke
celebration, continuity, maybe
gratitude for the founding,
right?
The success of the experiment.
Yeah, it's backward.
Looking in a celebratory way?
Exactly.
But shifting the focus entirely
to unfinished work does
something different.
It moves the narrative away from
celebrating the past and puts
all the.
Emphasis on moral debt, on
future obligations, on what's
still wrong, precisely.
It frames patriotism not as
pride in what was achieved, but
as responsibility for what
hasn't been fixed yet.
Which?
Strategically allows the
managerial class to participate
in the anniversary while still
keeping their position as the
nation's sort of moral
accountants.
The ones pointing out the flaws
that seems.
To be the idea, you get to weigh
the the flag, but your
participation is defined by how
critically you view the present,
not how gratefully you remember
the past.
So it's not.
Really about genuine pride, it's
more like responsible
participation, or participation
under protest almost, you could
see.
It that way, the emphasis stays
firmly on critique.
If your patriotism is all about
constantly highlighting failures
and listing systemic problems,
you.
Maintain that intellectual high
ground, that critical distance,
while still looking like you're
engaging with a national moment.
The celebration becomes an
audit.
Immoral audit.
Yeah, OK, so usualize the flag,
shift focus to unfinished work.
What was the 3rd objective this?
One the sources suggest is maybe
the most revealing about the
control aspect.
It's defining descent as the
highest form of love.
OK.
That sounds familiar, but and.
This is the crucial part.
Only if that descent passes.
Quote DEI review first.
So not all descent is created
equal in this framework
apparently.
Not that caveat passes.
DEI review first is key because
it shows the goal isn't just to
allow critique, it's to manage
which critiques are acceptable.
So certain.
Kinds of dissent are OK, even
encouraged, right?
If you dissent against things
like historical racism or
colonialism or things that align
with the current progressive
moral framework, that gets
framed as noble, as the highest
love because it.
Fits the approved narrative of
unfinished work exactly.
But what if your dissent is
aimed somewhere else?
What if you're protesting, say,
current corporate power or
global trade policies or the
actions of present day
institutions That kind of.
Dissent.
It doesn't pass the review
according.
To this analysis, no.
That kind of descent is more
likely to be labeled
problematic, maybe even
dangerous.
Or just ignore it's carefully.
Curated critique.
Not messy, inconvenient,
unpredictable rebellion.
Precisely.
The Heist tries to channel the
energy of American descent,
which can go in many directions,
and steer it only towards
targets approved by the current
elite consensus they want.
The look of rebellion, the moral
authority of the critic, but
without the risk of anyone
actually challenging their
structures or assumptions.
OK, so.
That's the plan.
Grab the symbols, change the
subject to debt, and critique
and control the acceptable forms
of dissent.
Sounds like a solid strategic
plan.
On paper it does.
But the sources argue that this
very attempt to stage manage
something as deep as national
feeling ran head first into a
major psychological wall.
They.
Miscalculated something
fundamental about people, about
how culture works it.
Seems so.
They misjudged the power of
belonging, the need for
sincerity, and, maybe most
importantly, the profound effect
of repetition and ritual, they
thought.
They could just execute a
communication strategy, but they
ended up.
Kicking off a kind of cultural
experiment that took on a life
of its own, moving beyond their
control, which brings.
Us perfectly to Part 2 the
psychology of conversion and
this really interesting metaphor
the sources use the rumspringa
yes the.
Rumspringa metaphor.
It's surprisingly apartment for
understanding this cultural
moment.
It captures that idea of
venturing out from a closed
world and being unexpectedly
changed by the experience.
Let's.
Just quickly define rumspringa.
For anyone unfamiliar, it's an
Amish term, right?
Right.
It refers to that period in
adolescence when Amish youth are
basically given a temporary pass
to explore the outside modern
world they can wear.
Non Amish clothes, drive cars,
experience things outside the
community before they.
Make that final lifelong
commitment to the Amish faith
and way of life.
It's a time of exploration and
the.
Expectation within the Amish
community, or let's use the
sources analogy, the Monastery
of Critique, the elite
intellectual world.
The expectation is that the
young person will go out, see
the modern world in all its
supposed corruption and
challenge, see the.
Barbarism perhaps, right?
And they'll come back horrified,
utterly convinced that the
cloistered community's way is
morally superior, reaffirmed in
their separation.
But that's.
Not always what happens in
reality, and the sources argue
that's not what's happening in
this cultural rumspringa either.
So the.
Progressive establishment forced
by the political need to engage
with patriotism.
The heist effectively sends its
members out on this cultural
rumspringa.
They have to.
Venture beyond their usual
spaces, their comfort zone of
constant critique, and they.
Stumble into what the source
calls the street Fair of
belonging, which is just
everyday mainstream America,
default America, and their.
Expectation, shaped by their own
theories and critiques, is that
they'll find ignorance, bigotry,
maybe.
That barbarism of unexamined
life.
They're probably.
Braced for it, expecting, you
know, the stereotypical negative
portrayals, the Walmart hats,
the Toby Keith music, the
simplistic nationalism they're
prepared to.
Be condescending, perhaps, to
observe and report back on the
flaws.
But then.
Something unexpected happens.
The experience on the ground
doesn't quite match the theory
right?
This is where the vulnerability
kicks in.
The potential for conversion.
The critical armor starts to
crack.
How so?
What do they find instead?
Maybe the?
People they expected to be
hostile are just nice, ordinary,
kind, even the food.
At the local event is actually
pretty good, even if it's not
artisanal.
Exactly.
And the feeling, that simple,
unselfconscious feeling of just
being there, being part of
something without having to
analyze it constantly.
That feeling.
Of just belonging without
needing credentials or a
critical take.
It starts to.
Feel like relief.
It starts to feel maybe better
than the constant, exhausting
work of maintaining moral and
intellectual superiority.
The sources.
Make a powerful point here.
Very few people come back from a
real rum spring, a completely
unchanged.
That taste of freedom, of
simplicity, of just grace.
It often tastes.
Better than perpetual critique
or resentment.
It's hard to go back to the
monastery once you've genuinely
experienced the street fair and
this.
Collision.
This unexpected emotional
experience connects directly to
the core psychological engine
undermining the heist.
Which is what it's the power.
Of pretending the inescapable
effect of ritual and
performance, they thought they.
Could just act patriotic,
maintain their internal
distance, but the.
Performance itself starts to
change the performer.
This is where.
That philosophical insight comes
in right the Jean Paul Sartre
quote mentioned in the sources.
Exactly.
Sarchers point that is
essentially you become what you
pretend to be.
The self isn't fixed, it's
shaped by its actions, its
performances.
Over time, the pretense becomes
reality and the.
Argument is that America itself
has always kind of run on this
magic in a.
Way, yes.
The idea that we as a nation
maybe faked ideals like equality
for long enough that the
performance itself started to
force us towards making them
more real, we adopted.
The rhetoric of high ideals and
eventually that rhetoric created
pressure for actual moral
action, right?
So the progressive elites,
according to this analysis,
thought they could strategically
cosplay patriotism, put on the
costume for a few years, manage
the optics for the 250th, and
then take it.
Off again when it was
politically convenient, but the
act.
Of putting on the costume, of
doing the performance, the
repetition, It starts to erode
the cynicism.
It's hard to maintain irony
indefinitely when you're
surrounded by sincerity.
If you.
Stand for the anthem every week,
even if you start doing it
ironically or if you show.
Up at the community flag
raising, even if you're
internally critiquing it
eventually.
The sources suggest the sheer
physical public act starts to
demand some genuine feeling.
The performance eats the irony.
Because at its core, the
patriotism of the default
Republic isn't really about
complex ideology.
What is it then?
It's.
Described as choreography.
Choreography.
Like dance steps, sort of.
It's the physical rhythm, the
shared routine, standing for the
anthem, saying the pledge, the
simple ceremonial gestures.
It's the bodily act of
participating in something
bigger than your own head.
It's about.
The doing, not necessarily the
deep thinking behind it,
largely.
Yes, it's permission to feel
affiliation, maybe even love for
something imperfect without
needing 1000 footnotes or
caveats and that.
Permission is exactly what the
highly analytical managerial
mindset finds difficult, because
their value lies in complexity,
in nuance, in critique.
Precisely.
Unselfconscious belonging is
almost countercultural in those
circles, so the performance
becomes a kind of trap.
A trap?
Set by our basic human need for
ritual and belonging.
How does that ritualistic part,
just the simple act of standing
up, say, breakdown the irony
through that?
Very unselfconsciousness.
Yeah, When you're busy
performing a detailed critique,
you're hyper aware of yourself.
You're the star of your own
intellectual drama, right?
You're.
Focused inward on your own
thoughts and judgments, but when
you're.
Just one person standing in a
crowd, shoulder to shoulder,
doing a simple shared action.
Yeah, that sharp sense of self
can kind of melt away for a
moment.
You become.
Part of the group, not separate
from it exactly.
And that momentary surrender of
individual intellectual control,
that's scary for the managerial
mind, but it's also the doorway
to just feeling something
sincerely, without analyzing it
first, That.
Idea of intellectual surrender,
of letting go of critique.
It seems like a good bridge to
the emotional undercurrent.
The sources identify this idea
of sublimated envy.
Oh.
Yes, this digs into the deeper
psychological motivations, maybe
the fuel beneath the political
conflict, the.
Argument is that the managerial
class?
You know, the ones who excel at
debate, analysis, credentials,
the theater kids, and think
peace poets.
As the source colorfully puts
it, they spent years, maybe
decades, essentially diagnosing
the warmth of ordinary American
belonging, the national bonfire,
as something negative, right?
As false consciousness or
provincialism or intellectual
simplicity something to be
looked down upon and in.
Its place they built their own
world, their own substitute
church, almost based on.
What based on?
Intellectual rigor.
Moral precision.
Policy Papers.
Perpetual awareness of systemic
flaws, a kind of liturgy of
critique and guilt they created.
A whole culture where status
comes from being the smartest,
most critical person in the
room?
Yes.
They built this impressive
structure of intellectual
superiority.
But the sources argue, something
was missing.
And that was.
That.
Basic fundamental human need for
simple, uncomplicated belonging,
for warmth, all the.
Policy papers and critical
theories couldn't replace that
feeling of just being welcome.
Exactly the simple grace of
being welcome without
explanation.
They built a world based on
critique but maybe sacrificed
the feeling of just being part
of the messy, warm national
family.
So it's a kind of deep seated
FOMO.
Fear of missing out, but not
about money or stuff, but about.
Emotional connection about
sincerity, about grace, Yes.
Envy of that simple grace.
They're the class that often
needs a credential, A
publication, a complex argument
to feel validated.
Whereas.
The default Republic, the
mainstream, just kind of lets
you belong simply because you're
there, right?
No entrance exam required and
this makes the 250th anniversary
a really tricky moment for them
because they.
Used to look down on the party
but now for strategic reasons
they feel they have to attend.
Yeah.
And they feel they need to
justify their presence.
They need a grand theory, a new
narrative, an intellectual RSVP
to explain why they're suddenly
showing up to the patriotic BBQ
they used to critique.
But the punch?
Line, according to the sources,
is that the default Republic
never actually required any of
that.
What did it?
Require just.
One thing, stop sneering, stop
looking down on the simple act
of belonging that.
Cultural condescension, that
intellectual superiority, that
was the only real barrier.
That was the.
Barrier they built themselves
yes the rest of America, the
default Republic was essentially
just waiting, maybe wondering
when they decide to join in and
the.
Ultimate irony here is that the.
Very act of trying to control
the celebration.
The heist itself forces them
into the rituals of belonging
the.
Performance demands sincerity
over time and the.
Default Republic, like a large
patient audience, is just
sitting there waiting for the
performance to end and the real
feeling to begin, which.
Leads us straight into Part 3.
Understanding this quiet, steady
counterforce the default
Republic right if the.
Heist is the loud, strategic
managerial attempt at control
from the top, the default.
Republic is the massive, silent,
immovable ballast at the bottom.
It's.
Described as the vast middle,
maybe 80% of Americans who exist
and operate somewhere between
the loud extremes you hear on
cable news or social media.
OK, so.
Define it more clearly.
Who are they?
What are they?
They are.
Baseline America.
Not the zealots, not the
ideologues, not the activists
constantly writing manifestos.
They're.
Defined more by temperament than
by a specific political
ideology.
Exactly.
That's a crucial distinction the
sources make.
It's not that they don't have
political views, but their core
identity isn't primarily
political or theoretical.
It's functional.
Functional.
Meaning.
They are focused on the
practical business of life.
They're what's left when all the
complex theories and passionate
arguments kind of burn
themselves out.
They hold a.
Basic belief that the country,
despite its flaws, is workable,
yeah.
Good enough to argue over,
flawed enough to fix, and worth
showing up for.
That's a quote that captures the
attitude.
It's a kind of practical,
grounded optimism.
Not naive, but functional.
And they are.
The ones who actually keep
things running, that's the.
Argument they are the
sustainers.
The source uses that great
analogy.
They're the rowers in the
galley, not the Cox, and
shouting slogans their.
Focus is on the actual effort,
the work, not the political
purity of the mission, right?
And how do they sustain things?
Through habit, often boring
everyday habits.
Paying taxes, running
businesses, teaching kids,
fixing infrastructure,
Volunteering locally, showing up
for jury duty, manning the ER
and.
Significantly, the sources
mentioned, they're the ones who
disproportionately end up
fighting the wars that the
elites debate in seminars.
Yes.
Their contribution is
fundamentally practical,
functional, and crucially, a lot
of this daily function is or
strives to be a political
meaning.
A teacher in the default
Republic teaches math or history
to all the kids, regardless of
their parents politics.
A firefighter puts out the fire.
A plumber fixes the pipes.
The function transcends the
immediate political fray.
And this.
Practical focus.
The sheer functionality makes
them the nation's indispensable
immune system.
That's a good way.
To think about it, yeah, they're
often too busy doing the work of
the country to get fully
consumed by the arguments about
the country.
So.
When faced with intense
ideological pressure, whether
from the left or the right,
what's their strategy?
It's not direct confrontation,
no.
The sources argue their
technique is much quieter, much
slower, but ultimately more
powerful.
It's absorption, absorption.
OK, the term used is cultural
Judo cultural.
Judo.
Perfect term.
It's quiet, it's relentless, and
the argument is it's
historically undefeated.
So instead.
Of fighting back directly,
arguing point for point the
default.
Republic uses the attackers own
energy, their own momentum, to
gently pull them into the
mainstream, into the civic
bloodstream.
It doesn't.
Crush the rebellion it.
Exactly.
It metabolizes it like a huge
slow moving Organism processing
nutrients or maybe pathogens
and.
History is full of examples of
this this national metabolism.
Absolutely.
The sources list several great
ones.
Think about the Puritans
started.
As the ultimate religious
zealots, Right focused entirely
on purity and God's law Utterly.
Ideological.
But eventually their descendants
largely abandoned that rigid
purity and became incredibly
successful merchants,
capitalists, entrepreneurs.
They effectively traded strict
theology for commerce.
Absorbed.
Into the practical economic life
of the nation.
OK, who else?
The revolutionaries themselves?
The firebrands of 1776, railing
against tyranny.
What happened to them?
Well, after the war, they had to
do the incredibly tedious,
practical work of actually
building a government, writing
constitutions, setting up
agencies, managing finances.
They became bureaucrats.
The revolutionary zeal got
channelled into functional
governance, domesticated.
By the demands of reality.
OK, more recent examples.
The hippies.
The ultimate 1960s
counterculture dropping out,
rejecting the system entirely
What became of.
Them.
Many of them.
As they got older, cut their
hair, got jobs and ended up as
consultants, therapists,
academics, middle managers, even
CEO's, they re entered the
system, often running some of
their values with them, but
fundamentally absorbed.
And your favorite?
Example oh the.
Anarchists ending up running HR
departments.
That is pretty perfect.
The ultimate anti establishment
figures becoming the ultimate
enforcers of corporate rules and
institutional norms it.
Illustrates the point
beautifully.
The system, the default
Republic, has this incredible
capacity to absorb and redirect
even the most intense
ideological energy.
So.
Applying this historical
pattern, the prediction for the
Great Patriotic Heist utterly.
Predictable it will be absorbed
the left's attempt to rebrand
patriotism as a form of
progressive therapy.
We'll meet the.
Same fate as the rights previous
attempts to claim exclusive
ownership of it.
Exactly.
Both will ultimately be
swallowed, diluted and
integrated by the slow, steady
functional center.
Because culture, the sources
argue, is built by osmosis, by
proximity, not by winning
arguments.
You just live.
Alongside the default Republic
long enough and its.
Habits, its temperament, its
focus on function to sort of
gets under your skin, it changes
you quietly and what.
Makes this absorption possible.
What's the mechanism?
The sources.
Identify the default Republic's
greatest genius, its secret
weapon, which is hostility and
forgiveness.
OK.
Now let's push on that a bit.
Is it really forgiveness or is
it just indifference?
If they just wait for the
passionate ideologues to get
tired and burnt out, isn't that
just letting the extremes fight
and then passively reclaiming
the space once they're
exhausted?
Like winning by default, not
through active grace.
That's a fair.
Challenge, but the source is
lean towards active forgiveness,
not just passive indifference.
Here's why.
Indifference is just not caring.
Forgiveness implies welcoming
back someone who actually caused
trouble, who disrupted things,
who held views you might
disagree with.
The default Republic seemed to
understand, maybe intuitively,
that ideological purity is
exhausting.
It's unnatural for most people
long term, so it forgives
hypocrisy, which is.
Something the managerial class,
often defined by its demand for
moral consistency and precision,
struggles with exactly.
The default Republic treats
ideological wandering that
apostasy not as some
unforgivable treason, more like
a.
Phase like growing up?
Yeah.
Kind of.
It seems to recognize that most
people eventually prioritize
connection, function, and
belonging over maintaining a
perfectly consistent ideological
stance.
Life gets in the way of purity,
so.
Picture the scene.
The cultural pilgrims, the one
sent out on the Rumpspringer.
They come back.
Maybe they're.
A bit sheepish.
Maybe they bought a flag pin and
aren't sure why.
Maybe they enjoy the local
parade more than they expected.
What kind of?
Reception do they get from the
default Republic?
Not scorn, not.
I told you so not.
According to this model, they
don't get interrogated about
their beliefs, they don't have
to sign a loyalty oath, they
just get handed a metaphorical
plate at the BBQ, told to pull
up a chair, included that.
Simple act of inclusion that
immediate, uncomplicated
welcome.
That's what the.
Sources argue is so powerful
that grace will undo more than
any argument ever could because
it.
Taps into that fundamental human
need, the 1 the intellectual
life sometimes denies right.
The need for belonging.
The managerial class might have
thought intellectual status was
the ultimate prize, but the
default Republic offers the
ultimate comfort, uncritical
acceptance.
Just welcome home.
So the.
Default Republic doesn't need to
win the debate, it just needs.
To endure, to remain open,
hospitable, functional, it waits
for the zealots left and right
to exhaust themselves with their
own intensity.
And then?
It offers them a seat at the
table, feeds them dinner, that
patience.
That quiet endurance is its
ultimate strength.
It doesn't argue with the
revolution.
It just keeps the parks
maintained for the next town
picnic knowing.
That proximity, shared space,
shared experience, those are the
things that really dissolve
ideological barriers over time.
OK, we've.
Laid out the heist, the
conversion, the default
Republic.
But history isn't simple.
We need to bring in the counter
argument the other side of the
story.
Absolutely.
Because not everyone interprets
this recent shift towards
patriotic symbols by
progressives as a cynical heist.
There's another way to frame it.
It is that this isn't deception,
but actually a necessary, maybe
long overdue reconciliation.
A kind of generational course
correction.
So instead of.
Stealing patriotism there.
Reclaiming it, Repairing it.
Exactly.
This view argues that
progressive patriotism isn't
trying to mimic the old ways,
it's trying to repair them.
It's saying that loving your
country must include
acknowledging its flaws, its
debts, its historical sins.
The.
Argument being that a living
Republic has to constantly
rewrite its own stories, its
myths, to align with its
evolving conscience.
It's changing demographics,
right?
If you just abandoned the
national symbols altogether, you
effectively hand them over to a
version of the past you might
disagree with.
But if you.
Appropriate the symbols, you
force them.
Into the present, you make them
relevant to today's challenges
and demand they live up to
contemporary moral standards.
You make the symbols work for
your vision of the country.
And there's.
Strong historical precedent for
this right for reformers using
the system's own language
against its flaws?
Absolutely.
The sources highlight this
pattern.
Think about the abolitionists
fighting slavery.
They didn't.
Invent a whole new philosophy
out of thin air, no.
They took the Founders own
words, liberty, equality,
God-given rights, the most
sacred texts of the Republic and
use.
Them, like a weapon against the
hypocrisy of slavery, they
demanded the nation live up to
its own stated ideals.
Brilliant.
Who else fits this pattern?
Franklin.
Roosevelt during the Great
Depression, facing economic
collapse.
He didn't.
Throw out the Constitution.
No, he.
Stole its language, phrases
about general welfare, national
security, the need for union to
justify the New Deal and
fundamentally reshape the
government's role in society.
He reinterpreted the founding
documents for a new era and the
most.
Iconic example Martin Luther.
King Junior during the civil
rights movement, he constantly.
Invoked.
Jefferson, Lincoln, The
Declaration, the Constitution?
Yes.
He masterfully stole the
cadence, the rhythm, the moral
authority of American idealism.
He wasn't rejecting America.
He was calling it home,
demanding it pay the promissory
note of equality it had written
at its founding.
So.
Seen through this lens, every
major period of moral progress
in America involved this kind of
appropriation, taking the old
symbols and infusing them with
new, urgent meaning.
And what?
Starts as appropriation.
Eventually becomes part of the
accepted story, part of the
Canon which brings.
Us back to the idea of
performance but seen differently
now if the current progressive
patriotism feels a bit scripted
or rehearsed this.
Counter argument says, well,
maybe that's OK.
Maybe that's how belief restarts
after a period of deep cynicism.
It's like a.
Civic rehearsal You have to go
through the motions, repeat the
words, do the rituals, and
eventually.
The feeling catches up,
sincerity grows out of
repetition and.
Maybe the bigger danger isn't
the slight awkwardness of the
performance, but the.
Total paralysis that comes from
being trapped in irony, from
being too cool or too critical.
To participate at all, you have
to start.
Saying I love this country, even
if it feels weird at first,
before you can actually start to
feel it again authentically,
it's like.
Tending a relationship,
sometimes you keep it alive
through ritual, through showing
up, even when the feelings are
complicated.
Maybe nations are like that too,
that.
Historical perspective is
crucial.
Patriotism hasn't been one
single thing throughout American
history.
It's constantly been redefined,
rebooted the sources.
Layout roughly 4 major eras, 4
distinct flavors of American
patriotism.
Let's walk.
Through them, what was the first
era one?
The Republic of Rebellion,
roughly 1776 to 1865.
The key.
Idea here patriotism.
Literally began as treason
against the British crown.
Loyalty wasn't to a king or a
piece of land, but to an idea.
The idea?
Of self government consent of
the government?
Exactly.
A radical idea.
Loyalty to a principle, not a
person.
And this.
Era culminates, obviously, in
the Civil War.
How did that change things?
Lincoln, through incredible
rhetorical and political effort,
redefined patriotism.
It wasn't just loyalty to the
founding documents anymore,
became loyalty to the Union
itself and to the moral struggle
to preserve it and perfect it.
It shifted.
Towards loyalty as moral labor.
The unfinished work he talked
about at Gettysburg.
Precisely.
The nation itself, the ongoing
effort, became the sacred
object.
OK.
Era 1 Rebellion and Union What's
era 2?
Era 2.
Civic Gospel, roughly 1890 to
1945.
The Progressive.
Era leading into the world wars.
What defined patriotism?
Then it got.
Tied very strongly to reform to
improving the nation.
Think Teddy Roosevelt muscular
citizenship so being.
A patriot meant building things,
cleaning things up, yes.
Building national parks,
fighting for public education,
advocating for safer food,
cleaner cities, these were
framed as patriotic acts.
Making America better was the
duty practical idealism, but
then the.
World wars happened.
How did they impact this Civic
Gospel War?
Tends to harden things.
Service, sacrifice, conformity.
These became the dominant proofs
of loyalty, especially in the
face of external threats like
fascism and later communism.
Dissent started.
To look suspicious, unpatriotic.
Very much.
So the emphasis shifted from
internal reform to external
defense and unity through
conformity, which leads.
US into era three era.
Three, the corporate flag and
the counter flag, roughly 1945
to 1975 post war America.
What's the?
Dynamic here on one.
Hand massive post war prosperity
in the Cold War turned the flag
into a ubiquitous brand.
It was used to sell everything.
Cars, soda, conformity, anti
communism, patriotism became
fused with consumerism and
national confidence.
The flag.
Was everywhere, but maybe a bit
superficial perhaps.
But then came Vietnam and that
shattered the consensus for a
significant number of people,
especially younger generations
and the cultural left protesting
the war.
Even burning the flag wasn't
seen as anti American.
It was.
Seen as the ultimate act of
conscience, protesting the
government's actions in the name
of higher American ideals.
Exactly.
So patriotism fractured.
It split into these two
completely opposed languages.
The language of unquestioning
loyalty to the flag and the
government, and the language of
critical protest is the highest
form of loyalty.
They couldn't understand each
other, the deep.
Painful split, Which brings us
to the 4th era, centered around
the last big anniversary Era 4.
Kitchen recovery the 1976
Bicentennial What was the.
Mood.
Then what was it about?
It was.
Recovery.
Collective cell therapy.
Really.
The nation was exhausted and
bruised after Vietnam.
Watergate, the deep cultural
divisions.
Centennial wasn't about deep
ideology, Not at all.
It was about feeling good again.
It was spontaneous grass roots
and often incredibly corny, like
small.
Town parades, people dressing up
in colonial costumes, lots of
fireworks, all of that.
Local mayors, scout troops,
ridiculous hats, red, white and
blue everything.
It wasn't managed by
corporations or think tanks, it
just sort of erupted.
A collective sigh of relief, a
desire for simple warmth and
unity, even if it was a bit
cheesy.
Exactly.
Kitsch and nostalgia ruled It
was about shared feeling, not
sharp ideas and the.
Contrast with the upcoming
250th.
Couldn't be starker, right?
1976 was spontaneous therapy.
2026, as the sources describe
it, feels like a meticulously
planned PowerPoint presentation.
Lots of.
Stakeholder engagement,
Inclusivity, checklists,
Carefully managed messaging,
Corporate branding, The
professional.
Managers are in charge this
time, replacing the spontaneous
eruption of feeling with
calculated strategy.
Yet.
Despite these huge differences
in style and management, does
history suggest an underlying
pattern?
The pattern.
Seems to be synthesis, the flag,
the idea of America.
It survives because it's big
enough to contain all these
arguments.
It ultimately belongs to whoever
keeps showing up, keeps
engaging, whether they're
emphasizing gratitude or
responsibility.
Both ends.
Of the spectrum are, in their
own way, performing an active
engagement of loyalty to the
ongoing argument that seems.
To be the underlying point, and
it leads to this interesting
observation about the present
moment, which is that both major
political forces right now, the
progressive critique and the
populist movement, seem to run
on a similar kind of fuel.
What kind of?
Fuel.
Is that theatrical?
Fuel performance.
Explain that.
How does it apply to both?
Well.
Take populism, maybe best seen
in the Maggie A movement.
The sources acknowledge it taps
into very real, authentic
feelings, resentment of elites,
frustration with certain
policies.
The emotion is genuine.
But often the expression of that
populism becomes highly
performative.
It relies heavily on rallies,
symbolic gestures, expressions
of outrage, a kind of political
theater.
The performance becomes central
to the identity, OK.
So populism has its performance
aspect.
How does that compare to the
progressive side in this
context?
Well.
As we've discussed with the
heist, there's a strategic
performance of patriotism
happening there, an attempt to
use the symbols and language for
specific ends.
So you have.
One side performing patriotism
as a strategy and maybe the
other side performing defiance
or authenticity as a core part
of its identity.
Something like.
That both movements seem to
place a high value on narrative,
on symbolic action, on the
theater of politics, sometimes
maybe even more than the nuts
and bolts of policy or
governance.
Interesting.
Parallel, just to clarify a
couple of things that came up in
the source materials FAQ
section.
Patriotism itself, it's not
inherently conservative, is it?
No, definitely.
Not historically, as we saw.
It's been claimed and defined by
reformers, revolutionaries,
progressives, conservatives,
everyone.
The real fight isn't over
ownership, it's usually over
tone.
Tone.
Meaning.
Do you emphasize gratitude for
what's been achieved for the
institutions?
That's often the conservative
tone.
Or do you emphasize
responsibility for the flaws,
the debts, the future?
That's often the progressive
tone.
But both can be expressions of
commitment, of loyalty and the.
Term heist.
It sounds provocative, Admit
literally not literal theft, no.
It's used because the analysis
suggests the shift was so
sudden, so strategic, and so
clearly aimed at neutralizing a
political opponents advantage by
taking over their symbolic
territory.
It implies a theft of meaning or
an attempt to steal the
emotional association of the
symbols for different
ideological purpose.
Got it.
OK, so through all this
complexity, the heist, the
conversion, the historical
shifts, performance on all
sides, what's the ultimate
outcome?
Where does the default Republic
fit in the ultimate?
Synthesis the long term trend
seems to be the quiet victory of
the default Republic, its power
of absorption it takes in.
The critics, the performers, the
ideologues through simple.
Contact through proximity,
through shared life.
Not by winning the arguments.
It just wears them down with
normalcy and belonging, which
brings.
Us to our final synthesis Part 5
and this great central metaphor.
The BBQ versus the bonfire,
right?
But just before we dive into the
metaphor, let's quickly nail
down that core difference
between the two big
anniversaries again, 1976 versus
2026.
OK, 19. 76 therapy.
Messy, spontaneous, emotional.
Maybe a bit cheesy.
A collective exhale after trauma
relief.
Managed, choreographed, branded,
professional, driven by strategy
and stakeholder engagement.
Calculated.
A huge.
Difference in approach a
massive.
Yeah, the sources argue that
underneath the 2026 management,
the same basic human instinct is
still there, waiting the desire.
For connection, for simple
pride, for belonging.
Exactly.
The desire that fueled the messy
bicentennial is still present.
Even if it's.
Buried under layers of corporate
speak and strategic planning,
the BBQ metaphorically still
smells the same, even if the
event has sponsors now and the
way.
The country finds unity, or at
least cohesion, around this
anniversary.
It won't be through some
brilliant new ideology winning
everyone over.
Unlikely.
The prediction is more grounded
unity, or at least a lessening
of hostility will come through
something much simpler,
exhaustion and proximity
exhaustion.
And proximity, meaning people
just get tired.
Tired of the constant anger, the
perpetual conflict, the high
intensity loathing.
The outrage machine requires
endless fuel and eventually
people run out of steam and.
Proximity being.
Physically near each other,
sharing the same space, the same
event, the same messy reality
when you're standing next to
someone you're supposed to hate
ideologically, maybe watching
the same fireworks, the.
Shared experience starts to
break down the walls faster than
any online argument.
That's the.
Idea.
The sheer uncurated functional
proximity of being in the same
national space together starts
to win out over the carefully
constructed narratives of
division.
The sources.
Paint a picture for 2026 maybe?
Activists chanting near
veterans?
Vegans.
Standing in line for food next
to hunters and this.
Slow realization dawns.
Huh.
We're actually all in this same
slightly absurd, complicated
boat together, yes.
The messy reality of shared life
overcomes the clean lines of
ideology.
That's the quiet power of the
default Republic in action.
And this.
Ties directly into that final
powerful metaphor, the fire
right the.
Idea is that every ideology,
every passionate movement trying
to purify or control things in
America eventually gathers
around some kind of fire.
And there are.
Two kinds of fire in this
metaphor 2.
Kinds.
First, there's the bonfire.
What does a?
Bonfire represent the.
Bonfire is the fire of
purification, of ideology, of
control.
It's where you shut your
theories, denounce the impure,
try to burn down the old myths,
and build everything a new
according to your perfect plan.
It's the fire.
Of the heist of the rigid
ideologues on any side.
Sharp, hot, maybe.
Exclusionary.
Exactly.
It's about being right, about
control, about defining who's in
and who's out based on belief
and the.
Other fire.
The other fire.
Is the BBQ.
What's the BBQ?
The BBQ.
Is the fire of communion, of
belonging, of forgiveness.
It's messy, smoky, loud, maybe a
bit chaotic.
It smells like cooking meat and
shared experience.
It's the fire.
Of the default Republic
inclusive functional, focused on
sharing food and space rather
than ideological purity tests.
Precisely The conversion is that
moment when someone tired of
shouting at the bonfire wanders
across the field, drawn by the
smell of the BBQ at the.
Bonfire, you have to prove you
believe the right things at the.
Barbecue.
You just get handed a plate.
The core test isn't faith, it's
appetite.
The American.
Story, then, isn't ultimately
about which ideology wins the
argument.
It's about.
Who shows up hungry?
The default Republic, The BBQ
rewards the appetite for
connection, for life, for simply
being together more than it
rewards doctrinal purity.
So when?
Those fireworks go off in 2026
across the whole country, the
analysts.
And commentators will rush in
with complex interpretations,
reconciliation, rebranding,
strategic wins and losses.
But the.
Underlying reality might be
simpler, much?
Simpler.
According to this view, it'll
just be America doing what it
always eventually does,
absorbing its critics, welcoming
them back, baptizing everyone in
noise and light and shared
space, forgiving them.
For being late to the party,
maybe, essentially.
Yeah, the BBQ always outlasts
the bonfire, OK?
A really rich analysis.
Let's try to boil it down.
What are the key takeaways for
you the listener trying to make
sense of this as we head towards
2026 take away?
Number one is about psychology.
Remember the power of
performance.
Patriotism, even if it starts as
strategy as a heist, can
actually become sincere through
sheer repetition and ritual.
You become.
What you pretend to be, that's
the.
Core idea Watch for that
conversion happening take away.
#2 understand.
The default Republic.
It's not an army fighting for an
ideology.
It's the nation's cultural
ballast, the quiet, functional
majority that absorbs extremes
through patience and proximity.
It wins.
By enduring, not by arguing
right.
And take away #3 America.
'S secret weapon, Hospitality
and forgiveness, yes.
The ability to welcome back the
way we're the critic, the
apostate, without demanding
apologies, just by offering a
seat at the table.
That cultural grace is
incredibly powerful and often
underestimated.
It undoes.
More than an argument ever
could, the sources wrapped this
up with a really potent line
about American loyalty.
Yeah, that.
Patriotism here isn't some fixed
doctrine you have to sign on to.
It's more like the world's
longest running, messiest open
mic night you don't have.
To love every act but.
You're invited to learn the
chorus.
Participation.
Trump's purity, which leaves.
Us with that final provocative
thought for you to chew on.
Think about it.
Personally, as you watch all
this unfold, as you participate
or observe the rituals and the
arguments leading up to 2026,
ask yourself this What part?
Of the national chorus, What
symbol, what ritual are you
currently engaging with?
Ironically, critically, with
distance and then.
Ask how long before the
repetition, the proximity, the
sheer gravitational pull of the
shared experience makes you
realize, maybe with some
surprise, did you actually mean
it?
How long before the performance
becomes real for you?